[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 204 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark, and I'm here
without a co-host, which
means no adult
supervision, which means
things are going to get wild.
[PARTY SOUNDS]
Actually, I think we'll keep
things pretty even keel,
and I'll just kind of
stick to the same format.
First up, I am happy to say
that we are interviewing
Ray Tsang, a developer
advocate at Google,
and we're going to be talking
a lot more about Java.
Java is obviously a
programming language
that many people
are familiar with--
[SLOT MACHINE]
--but I was super interested
in hearing what you can
use in Google Cloud with Java.
And Ray goes over kind
of the details for an end
to end Java
experience, all the way
from kind of writing code
to deploying, and testing,
and monitoring.
So it was really
great conversation,
and definitely looking forward
to going to the main content.
But I also want to talk
about a question of the week
that we'll have coming up,
which I will ask and then answer
myself, which talks
a little bit more
about building a
Docker file with Java.
We'll talk about using JIB.
Ray and I talked about
that a little bit as well.
Before we get into those, let's
talk about some cool things
of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So our first cool thing of the
week is that Cloud Run is--
[DRUM ROLL]
--generally available
for everybody,
which is super
awesome, because I'm
sure you've heard a
lot about Cloud Run.
And it's just been a
really cool product,
and people have been
really excited to use it.
And now that it's
generally available,
we'll see businesses try to
maybe adopt that a little bit
more, and be a little bit more
friendly about experimenting
with it.
It's a super, super cool.
You're able to take a container
and kind of just run it.
It's built on Knative.
And actually, last
week's podcast episode
talked a lot more
about Cloud Run.
So if you didn't get a
chance to listen to that one,
definitely recommend
checking it out.
Otherwise, go try
it out for yourself,
and see what cool
things you can host.
There's lots and lots
of opportunities there.
The other cool thing
I'd like to mention
is that there's a budget API
that's now available in beta.
Now this one lets you build
and kind of manage your budgets
from a programmatic standpoint.
The reason that's
really important
is because when you're
setting up a budget--
I think I talked about this
a couple of episodes ago,
but what you really want
to do is setup budgets
around your projects
to make sure
that you're not spending in
areas that you didn't plan
to spend on, whether that's a
product you didn't plan to use,
or whether it's just kind
of keeping a cap on your dev
environment.
But now that the budget
API is available in beta,
you can start to integrate
it with your infrastructure
management.
So if you're using
Terraform or something
like that to make sure that
you have easy to reproduce
and easy to control and
source coded configuration,
now you can include
your budgets in that.
So if you need to set up a
new project, or a new suite
of projects to use, or you
have new developers coming in,
whatever, you're easily
able to use the budget
API to kind of put
automatic budgets on that
without having to worry
about doing it manually.
So super, super
helpful, especially when
you get into more complex
project configurations.
So go check that out as well.
Lots of cool things offered
by Cloud Run and [? budget. ?]
But let's take the
conversation over to Ray,
and talk a lot more about what
the end to end Java experience
looks like on Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Ray, thank you so much
for joining us today.
First things first, who
are you and what do you do?
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
Hello.
Thanks for having
me on the podcast.
My name is Ray Tsang, and I'm
a developer advocate at Google
Cloud, and I focus a lot
on the Java developers
and Java community.
And I try to bring
some of the technology
that we have from GCP
to Java developers.
And the other side
of things I try to do
is, of course, to make
our platform run better
for the Java
applications, to be easier
to be used by Java
developers out there.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So I guess
one of the first interesting
questions I have out of that is,
obviously, Java has been around
for a long time--
Java has actually been around
longer than the Cloud probably,
right?
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
I think I started professionally
with Java development
maybe back in 2003, 2004,
or something like that.
It's been a while
since people have
been using it to write
their applications
and run their
enterprise systems.
TEXT TO SPEECH: The first public
implementation of Java 1.0
was in 1995.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
it sounds like you've
been working with it
since before the cloud,
and obviously have a
lot of expertise in it.
My first question
kind of comes down to,
what's different about
Java in the cloud?
RAY TSANG: Well, it depends
on how you want to run it
and what it is you're
trying to solve.
I think that from a
language perspective,
it's just another
programming language.
But when you are
running the application,
I mean, largely it can be
pretty much the same, I guess,
if you are accustomed to
running your application
via an application server,
or a web application server.
It's all pretty
much the same thing.
You just had it running
of your machine,
on somebody else's machine, or
on the machine in the cloud.
They are just
processing [INAUDIBLE]..
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So I've also read
that there's this new
announcement for App Engine
standard, right?
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
So for App Engine, that is
a platform as a service.
So it depends on what
you're looking for.
If you know you want to run
some existing apps with existing
ways, you can do that with just
cloud infrastructure running
with VMs, and set up
your own networking.
On the other extreme,
of course, is
to be hands-off on
all of those things
and give us the application
that you want to run.
And in a platform
as a service, we
will be able to provision
other resources for you,
the load balancer for you.
Even keeping the runtime
up-to-date for you as well.
With App Engine, it
can also automatically
scale your application out to
as many instances as you need,
or they can actually just
reduce the instances down to 0
if nobody's using
the application.
And this will give
you that elasticity
that you might be looking
for a certain workload.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So I
mentioned before that I'm not
as familiar with
Java, and certainly
haven't dealt with
it in a while.
But Java kind of
running in the JVM
is a long running instance--
usually pretty hefty workloads.
How does that
compare to something
like you just said
in the App Engine
when you're really working
on it serverlessly?
RAY TSANG: So I think that
there are many different forms
of the app.
It's just another language.
But certainly, I
think traditionally,
people may be running
their application
in a hefty application server.
Traditionally, a
very long time ago,
I think my application server
may start in 30 minutes--
like a whole update process
could be an entire night.
But that's not the case anymore.
I mean, it's been
a long time since I
had to do that, for example.
The community has
progressed so much now
that there are a lot of the
microservices frameworks that
helps you to put up a lot
faster, and focus on the things
that you want to do.
So for example, one of the most
popular one this Spring Boot.
This is pretty well-known.
It's very, very
popular right now,
and I see a lot of adoption of
it in production systems too.
And from a microservices
perspective,
it gives you
everything you need.
And you can still
start up your app--
your services in a
matter of seconds
as supposed to minutes
for that matter.
So that really helps.
And then there are
definitely newer frameworks
that just came out maybe
this year and last year--
things like Micronaut
and Quarkus.
In these new frameworks,
they take on the challenge
in different ways.
For example, in
Micronaut, they try
to generate a lot of the code
at compile time as opposed
to runtime, and then you can
link them together very easily,
and then you can just
run them very easily
without having a lot
of additional overhead
that you might incur if you want
to generate code at runtime.
And Quarkus is another
new framework from Red Hat
primarily.
And not only do they have
pretty fast start up speed to,
it allows you to use some of the
well-known standards like JPA,
and CDI, and a few
other things, or JAX-RS.
But they also focus
on the ability
to make sure that you can
potentially compile this
down into what we
call a native image.
So today, it's actually
possible to compile
Java code with Guava native
image down to native binary.
And you can actually start up
your application potentially
in sub-second.
Of course, this is
really, really new.
I don't know if I would
do this in production,
but people have tried it.
And I think all of
the frameworks--
the ones I mentioned all
have some level of support.
Micronaut-- since they're
all pretty much generated
at compile time,
all of these things
can be compiled down to
native image as well.
Quarkus has that support by
default. And Spring Boot--
I was at a conference here at
Devoxx Belgium just this week,
and I showed a demo of
Spring Boot that was also
being compiled down
to native image,
and that was [INAUDIBLE]
sub-second as well.
So I think the community
is really moving forward.
But even without this, I
think that couple of seconds,
I think that's pretty OK.
Even sometimes I see
heavier workload.
The promise of the
serverless to me
is not really just
about the startup speed,
because in all of these
environments like, say, App
Engine, you can also specify
minimum instances and the way
that you want to auto-scale.
So it's not absolutely
necessary for you to have
super fast startup time.
What is key here,
to me, is that you
don't have to manage
anything, [LAUGHS]
and that, to me, is really nice.
So for example,
[INAUDIBLE] the time
to figure out how to
create a potentially
compliant infrastructure
that can run your workload.
And this can take a
month of work just
to figure out what that
production environment looks
like, and how that
actually works.
App Engine is already a
production ready environment,
and you can just
give us a JAR file,
which is how most people produce
their application artifacts.
So you just give us a JAR
and we can just deploy that
into App Engine, and
everything gets bootstrapped,
and you just start to serve.
So that's pretty cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
I want to come back
to some of the points you
actually just mentioned,
but let's start with
taking a JAR file
and sending it to App Engine.
Now the latest
update for App Engine
is that it supports Java 11.
First of all, what does that
bring that App Engine didn't
have for Java before?
RAY TSANG: So I think there
are two primary things.
First of all is that it has
the new language support.
So there is newer language
support in Java 11
that's not otherwise
there in Java 8.
But I think the more
interesting perspective
will be the second part, which
is that traditionally, App
Engine takes a
WAR file, and that
is a web application-- a package
where-- you package-- you
structure your application
differently so that you can
run this in app server, like
Tomcat or Jetty or something
else.
But as the community progresses,
as new frameworks come up
and are being adopted--
even more popular--
people don't really want to
configure their app server
anymore, and they just want to
be the JAR file that just runs.
So locally, just a Javaless
JAR, and the application
starts just fine.
And you don't have to set up
any other additional components
except for your JVM.
Then you're up and running.
So I think in Java 11, we
switched the packaging format
from WAR to JARs to
serve this use case where
I do see a lot of people do.
And you can basically
deploy any JAR file
now as long as they start
up and listen to the port.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
So now you get a little bit
more flexibility because you
don't have to have
that web application
framework around it, plus it
sounds like it's a little bit
less overhead to get a jar
up and running in App Engine.
RAY TSANG: It's a
lot easier to do,
but there's still an
application framework
that you might want to use.
You can, of course,
make your application
without any framework,
but that could
be potentially a lot of work.
And of course, if
you do it that way,
the startup speed is
even going to be faster.
But if you want the convenience,
I think overwhelmingly,
people may still choose
to use a framework.
I think what is really
nice is that now, you
can use any framework
that you want
and expecting that
the same result,
and you don't have to modify
a lot of code-- or any code--
to be able to run
it in App Engine.
So for example,
in the past, maybe
trying to deploy a Spring Boot
application into App Engine
Java 8, the previous
version, and you
have to understand
how to convert
that JAR file that you're
really producing into a WAR file
with the right structure.
With Java 11 runtime, you
don't have to do that anymore.
And I have seen a lot of
people getting into trouble,
and it's hard to
understand what would it
take to convert this
package into a package
that the previous
version can run.
Now when I say previous
version, I really
mean that we are actually
having both versions
running at the same time.
So if you're on Java 8, and if
you are accustomed to the WAR
packaging, it continues to
use that, and you should.
But if you want to try JAR
application deployment,
then you kind of need
to use the new runtime--
the Java 11 runtime instead.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And like
you mentioned earlier,
you kind of have your choice
of frameworks, or none,
if you wanted to do it that way.
But that obviously
wouldn't be best practices.
And Spring Boot
was a big framework
that you kind of mentioned
as a popular example.
So what does Spring
Boot bring to Java?
RAY TSANG: So Spring Boot is a
really nice framework where--
Spring has been around
for a very long time.
Don't even remember
what year that
was when they first started.
TEXT TO SPEECH: Spring
Boot can be traced back
to its humble
beginnings in 2002.
RAY TSANG: And traditionally,
it was configured
through a lot of XML.
And when Spring Boot came along,
then the other configuration
became a little
bit more idiomatic,
and it focused on, I
would say, combination
over a configuration.
As opposed to in the past, where
we may end up with a giant XML
file that just determines
how you can run and serve
one endpoint, in Spring
Boot, you just create a class
called a controller, REST
controller [INAUDIBLE] to it.
And then you create a
method, and add a GET mapping
or a POST mapping
depending on the operation
you want to handle,
and off you go.
It takes maybe--
I don't know--
five lines of code
to serve an endpoint
today, and everything
can get started very easily.
My good friend, Josh
Long from Pivotal,
he always shows
how to get started.
He's got all the best
videos, I think, online,
teaching people how to do this.
And his favorite is, of
course, start.spring.io.
You can go to that site and
you can bootstrap a Spring Boot
application really,
really easily.
And you can also add G Suite
to support from start.spring.io
So in that site,
you can say I want
to create a web application,
and then you just
add a web component to it.
Or you can add a bunch
of other components,
and it'll just automatically
configure your app.
You click on Download, and
it generates the zip file,
and you unpack it.
You're ready to go.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So that lets you
start integrating with other
G Suite products a lot easier?
RAY TSANG: For Spring
Boot specifically,
we have a project
called Spring Cloud GCP.
So when you generate
that app, or when
you're configuring
a Spring Boot app,
you can add the Spring
Cloud GCP component to it--
this project has been created
by the cloud Java team
here in New York.
And once you add
the starter to it,
we have a bunch of
integrations with GCP services.
So if you are already
using Spring Boot,
you can add this Google Cloud
starter into your application,
then you can choose
what services
you want to integrate with.
So for example, if you only
use something like data store,
you have the option of
using a store API directly.
Or if you want
something more close
to what you are doing with
Spring Data, where you have
object relational mapping layer
on top of your application
so you can deal with POJOs,
or Plain Old java Objects,
and persisting that
into the database,
with a Spring Data
data store, you
will be able to do
exactly the same thing.
And I show this in
my demo quite a bit,
and the process of using
Spring Data for data store
is exactly the same as
you would with another SQL
based data store that's
supported by Spring Data JPA.
Similarly, we have
support for Spanner too.
So if you don't want to
use the Spanner raw API,
then you can use Spring
Data for Spanner,
and the process is
exactly the same.
You write the POJO annotated
with the right annotations,
and you implement the repository
interface, or just extending
the repository interface.
And within a few
lines of code, you
will be able to have a
[INAUDIBLE] access to the data
store itself.
So it makes the whole
process very, very easy.
And [INAUDIBLE]
to data access, I
think that more
importantly, especially now
with all a microservices
architecture
when we're creating more
and more small services
as can potentially calling
other services as well,
you kind of need to
know and understand
how the request kind
of flows through
from one service to another.
And for this people, try to
implement a distributed tracer.
And in Spring Boot,
there's already
a distributed tracer built in.
You get this tracer by adding
a starter configuration
called Spring Cloud Sleuth.
And as soon as you
add this starter,
without changing
any of your code,
you get distributed tracing
across those microservices.
And for us, for example,
for Spring Cloud GCP,
you can also add our starter
which will get you-- basically
uses the same Spring
Cloud Sleuth pipeline,
or the plumbing of
Spring Cloud Cloud.
It actually pulls in Spring
Cloud Sleuth for that matter.
So you configure your
application exactly
the same way that you
would as any other spring
cloud application.
But with our addition,
all the traces
will automatically flow
to stack driver trace.
So you don't have
to change any code,
so your application
becomes pretty much
agnostic to the environment
that you want to run in,
or to back end technology that
you want to integrate with.
Because in all of
these starters,
when you are adding
capabilities,
you don't actually have to
change your code in most cases.
Same thing with logging.
So if you want to
start driver logging,
depends on your environment.
If you are in Kubernetes,
you have two options.
You just do the regular logger,
which will just be plaintext.
However, because the log
message is not structured,
so the logger on the
start driver's side
wouldn't be able to
parse your message,
and understand the
different structure.
So for example, if
you actually add
Spring Cloud Sleuth
to your application,
or our starter to
your application,
every log message
that you print out
will be associated
with a trace ID,
because the trace
idea came through
from another microservice
to yours potentially.
And you propagate the
same trace ID downstream
to another service.
And when you produce
log messages,
the log lines are actually
associated with the trace ID.
What that means is that
given the trace ID,
you could potentially go
back to the login console,
you can type in the trace ID.
You can see all the
log messages associated
with that particular request.
However, if you just print
it out as plain text,
there's no way for us to parse
it and put in a special field
so we can query it better.
Another mode of doing this is to
output the log as JSON format.
So you can print your log
message in a structured JSON
format, and in this JSON
payload there potentially
is an attribute
called the trace ID,
and you have to put the
right trace ID in there.
But that's a lot of work to
do this yourself, so again,
with this Spring Cloud GCP
integration, what we're
able to do is to
automatically generate
this JSON payload for you.
And when you use the
logger and tracer together,
the result is
really, really nice.
What you get is,
for example, you
can see the distributed trace--
instead of a trace,
you can see what
are the services called
in this tree structure.
And for every one of these span,
for every one of these calls,
you can say "show
logs," and you actually
can see the log
messages associated
with that particular request
for that particular call.
It's super, super useful
when it comes too--
you need to troubleshoot some
issues-- you have the trace ID.
Or you know the issues--
you go back to your console
and you open up the
request that has the issue,
and now you can click in and
see exactly what happened.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
With Spring Boot,
it's pretty easy to get a
Java app up and running.
But really, you
want Spring Cloud
to take advantage of all
the cloudy atmosphere
stuff that you can use to
really kind of build, debug,
and integrate your Java app
with the rest of the Cloud.
RAY TSANG: Right.
And when you say Spring Cloud,
I think Spring Cloud in general
is an umbrella
project from Spring.
So they include a lot of things.
And so I think that Spring
Cloud in general, that umbrella
project helps you to run
applications in a cloud.
But Spring Cloud
GCP particularly
gives you the options
of integrating
a lot of these features directly
with Google Cloud Services.
And I think the end
result is that when
you run your application,
you focus on the app.
When you are ready
to add capabilities,
you can add these additional
dependencies so that,
without having to
change a lot of your app
or without having
to change anything,
you get these capabilities
added to your app automatically.
And now you're ready to
leverage the cloud native
services easier and
faster without having
to worry about the actual
implementation of that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What if you're
kind of working with an older
Java application, and you want
to migrate that to the cloud
instead?
So if you're using like
Hibernate or something
of that nature, what changes do
you need to make to get that up
and running?
RAY TSANG: So Hibernate has
been around for a long time,
and it's still being used a lot,
so it's not necessarily older.
But everybody who is
using relational database
is probably going to
be using Hibernate
somewhere in their
stack, or maybe
they just use JDBC driver.
But you can continue to
use hibernate, of course,
talking to our databases.
For example, we can talk to
our SQL databases on Cloud SQL.
We support Postgres
in MySQL, so that
should be pretty easy
to get started with.
But if you want to adopt
something like Cloud Spanner,
it is a relational
database that kind
of spans across
multiple regions,
and potentially across the
world with consistency,
which is absolutely amazing.
But to use Spanner, you
have a couple of choices.
Just recently, they have
released an open source JDBC
driver, where you can just use
the regular JDBC connections,
and you can do read and write
operations through JDBC.
However, if you want to
use it with Hibernate,
what is special about
this is that Hibernate
will need to understand how
to talk to the backend SQL
databases, because every SQL
database may have a slightly
different way of communicating.
They have different
SQL dialects.
So the team actually has
created a Hibernate dialect
for Spanner.
And at the time of
this recording--
this is still beta--
I don't know when they
are going to [INAUDIBLE]..
I heard it's going
to be pretty soon,
so it's definitely coming soon.
But at the time of the
recording right now,
you can actually give it a try--
that's in beta right now.
So what that means is
that it's not just there
to work with
existing applications
that's using Hibernate, but also
things like running anything
with micro profile that
uses JPA that uses Hibernate
behind the scenes.
You can actually integrate
that with Cloud Spanner
too to take advantage of
this really awesome database
architecture that Google has.
Or if you are using
something like Quarkus,
you can also use
Quarkus with JPA
with Hibernate
behind the scenes,
and then you can use the
Hibernate dialect for Spanner
to communicate and do cloud
operations with Spanner
as well.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So regardless of the
frameworks that you're
using, you still
have a good way to access
basically Google's databases,
but still being able
to run your Java code
in whatever way you mentioned.
Like you said, Kubernetes, you
can run it on an App Engine,
you can run it in a more
traditional Compute Engine
instance.
You have all those options.
RAY TSANG: Or even
if you are on-prem.
You can run it anywhere because,
I think, all of these services
are just APIs.
So if you have a fast
enough internet, [LAUGHS]
you should be able to run
it anywhere that you want
and still be able to
authenticate and get access
to the database
that you want to.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
one of the nice points
you mentioned is that by
putting it in the cloud,
you're also able
to take advantage
of all of the ops things
you can do with it, right?
Logging, monitoring,
debugging, tracing,
all these things that
are not as easily done
in some environments.
RAY TSANG: Oh, absolutely.
I think GCP Next,
San Francisco, I
did a talk that kind of showed
how everything works together.
So in the talk, I
showed how do you
get started with Spring
Cloud GCP with Spring Boot,
and how do you add some of
these data access options
with Spring Data,
Spanner with data store.
And then you can add
trace, and logging,
and a bunch of other
capabilities to your app.
And then it's just a
matter of picking what
the runtime environment is.
And you can containerize
your app, for example.
And the team also have
created something called JIB--
J-I-B. And this is a really,
really easy way, for example,
to containerize your
Java application,
producing a container
image without you
having to write a Docker file.
After you save
your Docker file--
everyone can write Docker files,
but to write it correctly,
it can be somewhat challenging.
You have to follow
many best practices.
So with JIB, we actually
implemented some of these best
practices, and they can produce
a very efficient container
image without you having to ever
write a line of Docker file.
And then you can push this
image to our Container Registry,
or another registry, whichever
that you need to push to,
and you can deploy that
container to the Kubernetes
environment or a run
environment for that matter.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And you can
integrate JIB with whatever
your build process is, right?
So if you're using like
Gradle, or Maven, or something,
it's very easy to just
containerize it and then ship
it.
RAY TSANG: That's right.
Yeah, JIB supports
both Maven and Gradle,
two of the most popular
build tools right now.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
from code to deployment,
it sounds like there's
kind of integration
points throughout the entire
stack of Java development
that kind of are addressed
by different parts of Google
Cloud.
We just talked about
the build, we just
talked about the framework
that's supported,
we talked about the
kind of operations piece
with logging and monitoring.
What about the IDE?
RAY TSANG: I think that
recently, the team has released
Cloud Code, and Cloud
Code is the plug-in
that you can add to your IDE,
specifically IntelliJ or VS
Code.
So for example, in the IDE, you
can create a new Spring Boot
application.
And from the IDE,
you can potentially
add App Engine support.
So directly from
the IDE, you will
be able to add whatever
is necessary to deploy
to App Engine without ever
having to go back to the shell.
And Cloud Code also
has the capability
of connecting to a
Kubernetes cluster.
So from Cloud Code, they give
you quite a few really nice
autocompletions
and everything, so
that when you're editing
the YAML files that's
specific to Google Cloud,
you can get autocompletion,
which is super awesome.
I show this in my presentations,
in my talks all the time.
And who remembers how to write
complicated YAML file, right?
But with some editor support,
it becomes fairly easy.
And potentially
from the IDE, what
you can do is to just Bootstrap
a brand new application
and then it actually has a
builtin template that shows you
how to create a Spring
Boot application
with the necessary Kubernetes
components or Kubernetes
files that you need to take
advantage of this plugin.
So for example, in a typical
Kubernetes development cycle,
you will need to create the app.
You need to use JIB to
create the container image,
and then you have to
write your Kubernetes
manifest-- the deployment
YAML files, for example.
And then if you
change some code,
you have to recreate the image,
and then potentially update
the manifest, and then re-push
everything to a Kubernetes
environment, whether it's
on your machine minikube,
or remotely in a
Kubernetes cluster.
And then you maybe test
it out a little bit,
and then if you
find another issue,
you have to redo
the cycle again.
And there's a really nice
tool called Scaffold.
It's a command
line tool that you
can use that basically automates
this development cycle for you
so that whenever you
change some code,
it can automatically
refresh the image,
and then automatically
push in that image
to the right registry, and
then automatically redeploy
the application for you.
And from your console,
from your computer,
without having to connect
remotely yourself,
it will actually
output a lock for you.
So you feels like
you're running your app
locally even though
it's actually
running in a remote container in
a Kubernetes cluster somewhere
or in your minikube.
And Cloud Code can integrate
with Scaffold really well.
So if you add Scaffold
to your application,
your IDE will say, hey, do you
want to add scaffold support?
And in IntelliJ, for example,
it will add a little Run button
that's specifically
designed to run
in Kubernetes in a
continuous deployment mode.
And you continue your
regular editing cycle,
and once you save the file,
it will recompile and recreate
the image, and
redeploy it for you.
It's really neat.
And the team actually
went even a step further
by adding the
debugging support too.
So like if we run
applications locally,
we can attach with
debugger so that you
can step through
the code-- you can
add a breakpoint in your code.
So you can add a
debugging point,
and you can step through the
code to see what's going on.
If you want to do that in
a Kubernetes environment
during development
time, of course,
then you can use Cloud Code with
Scaffold in the debugging mode.
And what that will
do is automatically
enable debugging
support in your app,
and automatically
attach the debugger
to this remote process that's
running a Kubernetes cluster.
And in your IDE, you'll be
able to debug this application
even if it's not running
on your local machine.
And this whole
process is seamless,
which is super, super neat.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: A great
place for people to get started
would be Cloud Code, because
all of the integrations
there really make the
entire development
process a lot easier.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
So for example, if you want
to also add Google Cloud
Services, even not using Spring,
even not using Spring Cloud
GCP, and you want to add some
client libraries in Cloud Code,
there is also a option for
you to connect to a service.
And from the UI, it will
allow you to determine
what service you want to use.
And once you select it, it will
enable the API for you which
a lot of people forget to do.
If you want to use
any API services,
you have to go enable the API.
The IDE will actually tell you,
do you want to enable this API?
It will generate the service
account key for you as well,
and then it will automatically
add the client library
to your Maven or Gradle build.
So you can very easily add
additional capabilities
to your application.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That
sounds pretty impressive,
because It sounds like
it really is designed
to take care of as
much as possible
for you, because it wants
to get you to the point
where you're just
worrying about the code.
All of the pipelines,
all of the work
that you need to do, and even
as much as integrating basically
the remote debugging.
All of it's right there.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
And of course, since
you mentioned debugging,
I think there's another
thing that a lot of people
don't know about.
I do this all the time--
I ask people who
are brave enough
to attach a real debugger
to your production workload,
and debug your application
live, [LAUGHS] or even
your staging environment?
It will be pretty
difficult to do, mostly
because when the
requests come in,
people have to wait for you
to step through the code.
So on Google Cloud, actually,
you have another debugger,
it's called Cloud Debugger.
And the difference there is,
for Cloud Debugger, what you do
is you add a Cloud Debugger
agent to your application,
and it will
automatically connect
to our debugger console.
And from there in
the console, you
can potentially
upload your code,
or see your code already if
it's running in a Git repository
that we have access to if
you give us the permission
to do it.
We can automatically
pull down the code,
or you can just upload the
code that you want to debug.
And in that console, you can
add a snapshot point as opposed
to a breakpoint.
And as somebody flows
through that flow
that you're trying
to debug, we'll
capture a snapshot of the
state of that moment in time.
And then you can inspect
the values and potentially
the code stack of
what actually happened
without stopping the world.
So the user is not
being affected by this,
but you are still able
to see the relevant data
that you need.
And what's funny is that I
did a joint talk with Robert
[INAUDIBLE] another cloud DA.
He actually focuses on Spanner,
but we did a troubleshooting
talk in the past, and
he made a joke like,
if you really want to
troubleshoot the production
environment-- this
is how he does it.
He does it binary,
log, debugging.
So what he does--
and I think I do
the same thing too--
is if something really
doesn't work out,
you need to see what
is actually happening.
You probably want to add
a log message somewhere,
because in the app,
they'll usually
have all the logs that we need.
But then you add a log to
the top at the beginning,
and you add the log
to the very end.
And the code doesn't
reach the very end,
you add a log
[INAUDIBLE] between.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very
familiar with that method.
Print one, print two,
print three, print four,
and then you're just looking
through streams of numbers--
like, oh, I see, the
code stopped at 37,
so let's work there.
RAY TSANG: Yeah,
[LAUGHS] exactly.
However, if you
had to figure out
where to add all these
37 things to log,
every time you
change the code, you
have to do another deployment.
If you're lucky, you can
get it through in minutes.
But I think in most
of the systems,
you could have to wait hours
before anything gets deployed.
So with a debugger, you can
also add log statements.
And it will at log statements
to your application in real time
without you having to do
anything additionally.
So you don't have to redeploy
or anything like that.
And it also does not affect
the state of your app.
We're not actually
modifying your code,
we're also not modifying
your application.
We're just adding
these interceptors,
these hooks, so
that we know when
you pass through
certain lines, we
will print out some
messages for you.
So pretty awesome tool that
very few people know about.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Sounds like it's
an amazing way to actually debug
in our production environment
with very minimal
impact to the user.
RAY TSANG: Right.
[INAUDIBLE] because in a
production environment,
most people may not
actually want anybody
to just go in and print
out anything they want,
or to see any of the data.
So I think that's
a real concern.
So this is really just
for break glass type
of scenario for specially
authorized users
to be able to do this.
And of course, you can
lock down who can do this.
You can disable this
by default, and only
when you absolutely need--
actually, I think
better use case
is probably like even staging,
or some higher environment
before you can
get to production.
During the QA tests
or the UAT tests,
some weird issue occurred.
Of course, we always say
it works on my machine,
but you never know
what the user entered.
And in a staging environment,
whatever that UAT tester may
have done, it will be
very easy to understand
what actually happened.
And I think a lot of people
are kind of afraid to get this
into production in most cases.
But everything can be locked
down, so that's the good news.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I'm convinced that if you just
label a server "production,"
that automatically makes
it buggier somehow.
[LAUGHTRACK]
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
[LAUGHS] You just get to see
all the scenarios that you never
saw before.
Who'd have thought this
is what people have done?
This actually happened
to me once where
I had a small
application-- a demo app,
and every time I
demoed it, it was fine.
When a product manager was
on stage demoing this app,
it errored out.
I was like, what happened--
what just happened here?
And I couldn't figure this
out until I actually went
to the instance and
used his computer,
retriggered this,
and reproduced it,
and then use the debuggered
to figure out, OK,
so the app asks you for
the name and the message,
and the person did
not enter the name.
And of course, I did not have
error catching for this one
because it's a demo app--
who would have known?
It says very clearly
"enter your name."
But who knew?
And this was a real scenario
for a very small use case,
and it definitely helped me.
And this actually turned into
a pretty fun talk as well.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Users
always find fun ways
to kind of interact with
your application in a way
that you wouldn't have expected.
I mean, if you're asking
them to enter a name,
you expect them to
enter a name, but you
can't guarantee they will.
[AUDIENCE GASPING]
RAY TSANG: Exactly, exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All right,
well, I think we are just about
out of time.
But before we go, Ray, is
there anything upcoming
that you're excited to talk
about, or any conferences
you'll be going to?
RAY TSANG: So this is
the end of the year,
and I'm very happy that I
don't have much going on
for the rest of the year.
But there's definitely
many other Java conferences
out there.
It is very, very
active, and I also
try to be in person
for many of them
so that I can meet and chat
with the Java developers.
So if you happen to attend
some of the Java conferences
or the local Java user
groups, let me know.
And I look forward to be
able to meet all of you
out there in person,
because I love to talk
to people in person as well.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Awesome.
And we'll make sure to include a
couple of key links in the show
notes just for people who
are interested in trying out
some of the things that we
talked about here today.
But Ray, thank you so
much for joining us,
and hopefully, we get a
chance to chat again soon.
RAY TSANG: All right,
thank you for having me.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Thanks so much to Ray
for coming in and
talking about Java.
I haven't used Java
for quite some time
any more than just
kind of playing around
with a few things.
So it was really exciting to
hear about all the new things.
He was also on the podcast
quite a while ago--
maybe two or three years ago--
talking a little
bit more about Java.
So if that's something
that is interesting to you,
definitely recommend
going to check that out,
and hearing a bit
more about how it's
probably changed, or
just stay tuned with all
the cool new Java stuff.
Speaking of which, we've got
our question of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So the question of the week is,
how do I describe my Java app?
So I've used plenty
of Docker files,
but it's usually
copied and pasted
from the base template, and
then slight modifications.
They can get pretty complex
and pretty unwieldy.
So the answer to
this question is JIB.
And JIB is built to
kind of integrate
with your current Java
development workflow,
and help you build your
Docker files without needing
to kind of get into
the complexity of them.
So the idea is that you
basically just kind of put it
in the configuration.
If you're using Maven or
Gradle, it's pretty simple,
or you can just
use it by itself.
And then you just
point to a place
to host your actual Docker file.
And from there,
you're good to go.
It's really, really
simple to set up,
and actually, there's
a fun little video
that just got published that
shows you how to use it,
and then links over to
the official documentation
so you go check that out.
But it's a pretty
simple process,
and I think it's really valuable
for being able to containerize
and deploy your Java
application without having
to worry about what's
going on-- without having
to worry about all the
configuration management.
It's just so much more easy
to put together a Docker file
based on what your Java app
is, and then move along--
focus on the actual part that
matters, which is your code.
So check out the video,
definitely check out
GIB on GitHub.
And then if it's
interesting, give it
a shot-- see what
you can do with it,
and see how it can kind
of make that whole process
a lot easier.
TEXT TO SPEECH: That's awesome.
This week, I'm spending
time playing video
games with my dog.
What about you?
What are you up to?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So this week is
going to be a busy week,
because we've got lots
of events happening right now.
We've got Google Cloud Next over
in London, as well as KubeCon
and Cloud Native Con are
happening right about now.
So I can imagine it's going
to be a pretty busy week.
We've got lots of people
out and traveling.
I've opted to kind of stay
behind in the Bay Area
and get some work done.
So hopefully, I'll
be able to do that,
but there'll be lots of exciting
announcements coming out
from those videos, interviews,
all sorts of things.
So definitely stay tuned
for the next week's episode,
because I'm sure we'll
be recapping some of that
as well as checking
out the Google Cloud
blog, and the Google
Cloud YouTube channel,
because there's
going to be probably
a ton of stuff coming
out from those.
Definitely excited to
see what comes out of it.
Well, that's going
to wrap it up for us,
so thank you all for listening.
And we will see
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I really should have just
done the podcast with myself
as two people--
something like,
hey, Mark, tell me
more about how to use JIB
to Dockerize my Java app?
Well, Mark, you can do--
or I could use robo-Mandel.
I think we may have
played out robo-Mandel.
We'll see.
TEXT TO SPEECH: I'm so sad to
hear that you feel this way.
It's hard being an AI
clone of a past host.
Just give me one more chance and
I promise I won't let you down.